hey everyone Perry and Adam back here
again we've got another review from TIFF
2018 for you this one is of joel
edgerton second directorial effort it is
boy array starring Lucas hedges and he
is a young gay men who is being forced
to go through a conversion therapy by
his his parents here and I just saw this
one this is actually the first this is
the last movie I saw and this is one of
those ones it's making me think a little
bit about beautiful boy and it's not
just the boy comparison I know we keep
going back with that but it's one of
those things where especially where it
ends to you need to kind of let it sink
in and process so the thought of talking
about it right now is a little
overwhelming but I I was incredibly
moved by the story yeah I thought it was
okay it's it's interesting it's based on
a true life story and it's written a
directed by Joel Edgerton who is an
actor who in like right but then also
wrote directed the gift like an
incredible horror film this is a very
different follow-up film for him it's
not a horror film well in some ways it
is yeah it's and it's based on you know
a true story and the kid grew up in a
very religious household his father is a
pastor to be his mother's very
conservative in Arkansas and I felt like
when it came to the the religious stuff
of it I found myself wanting to know
more about the titular boy about how he
felt because it's very clear that you
know at the beginning of the film he he
feels like he wants to change or at
least he says he does and and this is
what they've been taught is that what
they feel is wrong and they're gonna
write it by going to this gay conversion
therapy I never really got to see that
internal struggle of the character
played wonderfully by oh my god he's
something else who is obviously everyone
saw Manchester by the sea and was like I
want him in that movie as he's in Lady
Bird here he has three films here are
three films here sadly I'm missing one
of them but even just seeing seeing this
movie after having seen him in midnight
because midnight I sleep late he plays
like a tough boat yeah he just has so
much range it's insane yeah he's a
chameleon but I found myself wanting to
know more about you know how does he
himself reconcile his faith with his
sexuality someone who has grown up in
this very strict religious household I'm
told that it's wrong
how does like where does he feel about
his religion it was kind of what I was
looking for and I felt it it felt a
little short on that regard but in
telling a story about this gay
conversion therapy camp I thought it was
very effective Joel Edgerton plays the
the leader of the camp with dubious
credentials which is how a lot of these
camps go and there was recently a really
great profile in the news I can't
remember the outlet that came out about
an all-girls gay conversion therapy that
was really terrifying so this is a
natural thing that's happening and I
feel like it's an important story that
needs to be told but I was so so in the
execution applying the term horror to
this movie I think is very appropriate
because the second you brought that up I
went back to one particular scene where
you know that feeling where you're
watching a haunted house movie and
you're going through the halls and it's
like I gotta get out of here it's got
that quality to it and it really it just
it kind of rocked me in my seat where I
got I got very panicked at a point for
him yeah but um in terms of what you had
brought up at the very beginning I think
it's because of where they start the
story - because they do start it right
right at the at the onset of him kind of
managing you know who he is and dealing
with his parents expectations and I'll
definitely agree that I didn't really
see much of the the religious connection
or at least the wheels in his head
turning as it relates to what his father
is doing and how he grew up in a
religious household but what winds up
happening with that for me that that
left me in a very satisfying place in
that respect I'm not gonna spoil
anything here but there's one particular
line towards the end of the film that
kind of put everything into perspective
so beautifully for me where it had
meaning for for his character for
multiple characters in the movie but
that's the kind of message that you walk
out of that theater and you put it in
your back pocket and you always remind
yourself of it no matter what situation
shanira no matter who you are who you're
dealing with you think about stuff like
that and it was a very nice powerful
thing to be able to take with me yeah I
will say I really liked how the parents
were portrayed in this film Russell
Crowe plays the father and Nicole came
to plays the mother but when Lucas
hedges comes out to his parents the
father doesn't beat him the father
doesn't disown him it scared that it's
clear that his parents really care about
him but they come to the wrong
conclusions about what to do and we see
them kind of wrestling internally with
what's going on and they both have two
different perspectives on it as often
times happens in these kind of
conservative households and their
reaction almost reflects this this rule
book that he gets when he goes into this
conversion therapy where you know it may
it may sound it may sound easier to just
be able to fall back on rules or
something written in black-and-white on
a piece of paper rather than to
challenge yourself to accept and
understand something new and having that
idea in so many different elements of
the story I think it all came together
really well when I think about that
particular thing but you know he's just
an exceptional director and this this to
me has been a festival that has
highlighted so many actors turned
directors in the best way possible I
still can't believe what we've gotten
from from Edgerton now from Jonah Hill
from Bradley Cooper so I am really
definitely thrilled with how boy arrays
turned out and I'm also excited to see
what he does next especially with what
you brought up this is in it's a
completely different film compared to
the gift there's basically no
similarities whatsoever and I really
think he did a great job and Lucas
hedges is something else and Nicole
Kidman's performance is fantastic and
this will also get to talk about
destroyer to but she is another one
who's been a chameleon at this festival
just completely has law I've seen both
movies now and you'll hear about this
more in that review but loses herself
and you know so did Russell Crowe - yeah
the two of them I mean when you have
such a powerhouse a list status person
in a role I feel like their work becomes
even harder and harder to actually lose
that star persona in the character
they're playing and they they do it
exceptionally well here and
even even some of the other the other
teenagers in that group - I think they
make a big impression I wish I wish I
can remember that that one
yes Canadian filmmaker and then Troye
Sivan whose choice of on I think he's a
YouTube star okay I think he's probably
the one that I'm talking about but uh
they all made they all made a really
great impression in just the way that
Edgerton captures all of that again it
goes back to what I was saying about
horror where it kind of locks you in
that situation and it is extremely
frightening and heartbreaking but you
have to go on the journey to figure out
their essence and it is very clear that
hedges I mean I was talking earlier with
colliders Matt Goldberg about
I mean hedges is gonna win an Oscar
someday he feels like he's in that early
Matt Damon stage where Matt Damon was
like doing stuff like courage on fire
talented mr. Ripley it's just a matter
of time yeah it's a chameleon I mean
here in Boyer raised he's a closeted
religious gay kid in mid 90s he's an
abusive older brother in the 90s who's
kind of macho and into hip-hop and in
Venice back he plays an addict too his
mother Julia Roberts and all three
completely different films completely
different roles and he just disappears
in each one all right the time has come
it's a great time would you give this
one I gave a c-plus okay all right I I'm
a little higher on this one actually a
lot higher I'm going a b-plus I the the
way this whole story was constructed but
I think more than anything was the
feeling that I walked away with I mean
most of the time when I figure out a
grade it is it's relying on many
different things when I experience a
movie but more so than anything it's
about that feeling that I walk away with
and and I was uh I was like a little uh
overwhelmed by the whole thing and I
really appreciated the the sentiments
that it left me with so it is a b-plus
for Boyer race there it is that's our
review guess what we've got even more
for you so keep an eye on the Collider
video YouTube channel and also Collider
quicks we've got more tip coverage on
the way
[Music]